[Music]
I hear aloud your Parenthood castmates
are hitting the carpet tonight are they
that would make me really happy I love
that you're coming out to support your
old TV brother any kind of advice you
need seriously he's probably one of the
smartest people I've ever met I remember
really early on I played him in Scrabble
and he kicked my ass so much it like
wasn't even funny are you watching this
is us because there are a lot of
comparisons to Parenthood I have not
seen it but I hear it's great and I hear
it's a hit as well I've only seen the
first episode but I love the device of
like the time travel stuff is amazing
and I feel like it's all we're all one
big family all that it's kind of just
like another generation of fans are
saying they reap as much on that
watching that show as they did on Paris
I love that I'm glad there's something
else making making the people cry I mean
I think it's time to revisit the
Bravermans don't you think like a reboot
right now I think you know I think it's
definitely on the table and I think like
you know once sort of some more time
passes where we can tell us um a whole
new set of different stories we'll we'll
get back into it I think would be more
form of like a Netflix or maybe a movie
you know I really don't know I kind of
defer to Jason Katims on that one I just
think there's so many things you could
do because you have so many generations
of stories being told so I'm always down
[Music]
you